dolly parton has withdrawn her rock and
roll hall of fame nomination after uh
receiving the nom back in february dolly
shared a statement on social media this
morning saying she doesn't feel she
deserves it writing this
even though i'm extremely flattered and
grateful to be nominated for the rock
and roll hall of fame
i don't feel that i have earned that
right i really do not want votes split
because of me so i must respectfully bow
out yeah dolly added this i do hope the
rock and roll hall of fame will
understand and will be willing to
consider me again
if i'm ever worthy this has however
inspired me to put out a hopefully great
rock and roll album at some point in the
future which i've always wanted to do
dolly also gave a sweet nod to her
husband carl
excuse me carl dean adding that he has
always encouraged her to put out a rock
and roll album
i love that now dolly's nomination was
her first for the rock and roll hall of
fame the 2022 nominees also include
lionel richie eminem pat benatar duran
duran dion warwick and many more
so what are your thoughts on this carlos
do you think dolly deserved her
nomination
anyone watching right now knows that
morgan and i are the dolly part
appreciation society like
this is just another great dolly parton
move in that
she has so many accolades and however i
don't know how she defines success for
herself
but she is confident enough in what she
does and what she has done that she
doesn't need to be up for an award that
she feels like she hasn't done
the thing for like she hasn't made a
rock and roll album therefore why would
i be in the rock and roll hall of fame
how many people can say that they are
confident enough to do that
it's so true and and you know she does
it with respect she even wants the you
know committee of the the rock and roll
hall of fame to consider her again if
she feels worthy i mean i have heard
time and time again especially recently
i've interviewed a lot of people about
dolly parton especially at the academy
of country music awards she was hosting
and they just keep saying how humble she
is how lovely you know and and this is
just another example like you were
saying but it's interesting because i
was curious so when you look at you know
country artists who have been inducted
uh over the years into the rock and roll
hall of fame you've got brenda lee
johnny cash elvis presley
chet atkins hank williams the everly
brothers i mean it goes on and on but i
get it she's taking like the rock and
roll title like quite seriously um and
now i'm actually just excited for her to
put out a rock and roll track what about
you
i don't even know what that would sound
like
i think people take for granted
sometimes the idea of inducting someone
into the rock and roll hall of fame yeah
because rock and roll and other genres
of music are so tightly linked together
um but in dolly parton saying no no no i
i don't deserve it because i haven't
done a rock and roll album it totally
opens up the conversation of if she
dedicated herself to a proper rock and
roll album like that sound the way that
she hears it and the way that she
imagines it to be
what would that sound like and i'm sure
it would be amazing like that's probably
the answer would be amazing but i love
the idea that she's going to go
carl dean her husband has said you know
you should really do one you should
really do and maybe she just hasn't i
don't know if she hasn't really felt it
or if she hasn't thought i don't know my
the right way into it but now that we
have this opened up as a conversation i
totally want to hear it i know same and
i love that she gave that nod to her
husband i mean
this is such a private couple and
they've been together forever so it just
makes me love them even more a code red
is saying absolutely she deserved her
nomination i completely agree b bean is
saying yet rock and roll hall of fame is
not just for rock and roll uh and yet
she absolutely deserves it so yeah i'm
really excited i
think she 100 is gonna put out something
along the lines of rock and roll cannot
wait for that um she's just such a class
act i love her i want to be your best
friend
100